si fueron esos jóvenes pero cuando se
les preguntan las razones por las cuales
no votaron son muchas primero dicen que
fueron dos años después ellos también
pedían elecciones anticipadas en octubre
de 2010 19 si bien es cierto una
pandemia para ellos llegaron demasiado
tarde segundo siguen sin creer en esta
clase política dicen que los viejos
partidos políticos los viejos políticos
que se están acusados de corrupción de
olvidarse de la población de traer
pobreza de nueva de empleo de tener
hospitales que no
satisfaciendo por lo menos no no pueden
curar y no pueden ayudar a la población
iraquí siguen estando en el parlamento y
siguen estando en estas listas es cierto
que esta nueva ley electoral que también
llegó como respuesta a esas protestas de
2019 traía la oportunidad para que
candidatos independientes se presentaran
realmente esos quedan opacados por ese
gran monstruo eso de los partidos
políticos muchas veces divididos por
sectas en el país y que también acusan a
muchos de ellos pertenecer a estas
milicias muchas de ellas apoyadas por
irán que mantienen armas fuera del
estado lo que también es criticado por
estos jóvenes que ayer decidieron no
votar